becoming a billionaire is hard as of
april 2021 there were only a total of
2755 billionaires in the entire world
meaning that only 1 in every 2.8 million
people reached the elusive 10 figure
mark given the extreme difficulty of the
task it's not surprising that most
billionaires spend their entire careers
working towards ten figures with the
average billionaire taking 21 years to
reach the mark even the most notable
billionaires in history including bill
gates steve jobs and elon musk took over
a decade to make their first billion one
entrepreneur named jay walker however
managed to accomplish this feat within
just 12 months which is the fastest in
history so here's how jay walker made
one billion dollars in one year
taking a look back jay walker was born
to an immigrant family on november 5th
1955 in queens new york his mother's
family had fled to new york from germany
right before the start of world war ii
meanwhile his father's side of the
family had lived in the us for a few
generations and even made some good
money during the roaring 20s from a very
young age jay found himself embarking on
endeavor after endeavor trying to make a
bit of money here and there he sold
candles seeds and jelly door to door and
he delivered newspaper to his community
as he grew older jay became even more
involved in the community joining
student government nowadays student
government is more or less just a resume
patter but back in the day it seems like
jay actually played a pretty active role
in the community
one time he was the student
representative in a debate between the
teachers union and the city of yonkers
during a funding crisis anyway
jay ended up graduating from high school
in 1973 and he would go on to attend
cornell university where he majored in
industrial relations jay later revealed
that the motivation behind getting this
degree was to hopefully score a spot as
an assistant to an extremely wealthy
individual jay strongly believed that
understanding how wealthy people
operated was essential in becoming
wealthy himself jay didn't stick around
at college for too long though as he
would drop out and try to start a
business
unfortunately though this didn't go too
well
jay started a free weekly newspaper in
ithaca new york things started off great
as jay quickly grew to 175 employees
with 25 000 newspapers in circulation
however his business would crumble when
the local daily paper company came out
with their own weekly newspaper jay shut
down his newspaper business and returned
to college shortly after but now he had
150 thousand dollars in debt or 675 000
today
jay would graduate in 1977 and get a job
at a magazine company called folio after
college he worked on the marketing side
for folio for about four years before he
quit and tried to start another company
called the visual technologies
corporation the company sold glass
sculptures that emitted light whenever
someone touched them while these
sculptures had some novelty they didn't
really serve much of a purpose jay also
quickly found out that the sculptures
were extremely expensive to manufacture
just a few years after starting the
company visual technologies corporation
would file for bankruptcy in 1986 having
lost a painful 5.3 million dollars
jay didn't quit though he instantly
switched to running another business
called catalog media corporation jay
partnered with transworld airlines to
offer discounted flight tickets to
readers of the catalog
jay actually managed to sell a large
amount of discounted tickets however
there was a problem jay had been selling
the discounted tickets to travel agents
as opposed to end consumers which was in
violation of the contract with
transworld airlines trans world airlines
would sue catalog media corporation and
this company would also be shut down in
1988
at this point jay was only 33 years old
but he had already run three businesses
into the ground losing millions of
dollars and destroying his credit
nonetheless jay still wasn't ready to
give up in 1991 jay would form a joint
venture with one of his biggest
investors over the years michael loeb
this business was called the new
subservices and it specialized in
selling magazine subscriptions through
credit card companies
the company didn't skyrocket or anything
but for the first time in j's career the
company also didn't shut down
in fact this company is still around 30
years later and they go by the name
synapse group they employ about 170
people today so nothing is super insane
but also nothing to scoff at jake would
have just stuck around at synapse group
and he would have done extremely well
but jay had even larger ambitions so in
1995 he would start yet another company
called walker digital jay was a massive
fan of thomas edison and he wanted this
company to basically be a digital
version of thomas edison's laboratory
at first jay dabbled with some software
that could be used in restaurants but
soon enough jay would land on his
billion dollar idea buyer-driven pricing
buyer-driven pricing is when consumers
tell companies how much they're willing
to pay for a service or product and then
the companies will do business with
customers with reasonable offers
this business model was especially
attractive within the airline industry
consumers wanted discounted airline
tickets and airlines were often willing
to get rid of empty seats for below
market prices spotting this massive
opportunity jay went ahead and applied
for a patent for the business model
and fun fact this was the first time
that the u.s patent office granted a
patent for a business method
after receiving his patent jay founded a
company called priceline.com in april of
1998.
jay partnered with a plethora of
different airlines but despite that
during their first year of operation
only about seven percent of customers
were actually able to buy a ticket
through priceline
honestly though this wasn't that big of
a deal if you were planning on traveling
somewhere you could make a bid for a
flight ticket on priceline if you were
lucky you'd get a discounted ticket if
not you can just buy a ticket at market
price
in other words there was no reason to
not give priceline a shot and this made
priceline extremely popular amongst
consumers
despite this monumental demand priceline
was losing a lot of money but given that
investors were more than happy to back
internet companies at the time their
financial shortfall wasn't that big of a
deal
in april of 1999 one year after founding
the company jay took priceline public
and as you would guess the stock
exploded priceline ran up to a valuation
of eleven point eight billion dollars
and j stake ballooned up to 5.2 billion
dollars jay had finally made it as an
entrepreneur and so he decided to
celebrate jay bought himself a third
mercedes and he started construction on
his dream mansion
jay didn't get complacent though he
continued to aggressively expand
priceline for example jay worked quite
hard to get actor william shatner on
board
at first william didn't even want to
meet with jay
so jay agreed to pay william to have a
meeting with him during the meeting
though william would become so impressed
with jay that he agreed to do the ads
for stock compensation as opposed to
cash compensation
jay also tried to expand the business
model to groceries and gas as well with
the launch of priceline web house though
there was a large amount of demand from
consumers for the service the logistics
of running this business were a
nightmare
but little did you know that this was
the least of its concerns in early 2000
the dot-com pop-up burst and valuations
of all internet and tech companies fell
off a cliff jay wasn't faced by the
crash though he was like i'll just buy
the tip at these discounted prices and
hold until the stock recovers
unfortunately though jay wasn't buying
the dip he was buying a downtrend to
make things even worse 911 would kill
consumer demand for airline tickets and
this would push j over the edge
at the end of 2001 jay would shut down
priceline web house and sell his entire
stake to hong kong investors in
retrospect jay literally sold at the
bottom
i'm really not sure why he did this
he could have sold when he was down 50
60 even 80 percent and he could have
still walked away a billionaire but
instead he decided to sell when he was
down 94
on the bright side this still came out
to about 333 million dollars after taxes
but when you're down 94
you might as well weather out the storm
and stage your recovery i know that's
easy to say in hindsight but many
entrepreneurs like jeff bezos and steve
jobs did exactly that given the
resilience jay showed in the 70s and 80s
by starting business after business this
decision is quite confusing but whatever
the reasoning this is what jay ended up
choosing anyway after the dot-com crash
priceline stock didn't really move for
another five years priceline started to
make a recovery in 2006 and 2007 but
they got crushed once again by the 2008
financial crisis
it wasn't until 2009 that priceline
really started to grow once again
but they haven't looked back since then
in the 2010s priceline went on a buying
spree acquiring everyone from kayak and
opentable to hotels combined and venga
at the end of 2013 priceline finally
broke out of their dot-com peak and they
have over doubled since then
in 2018 the priceline group changed
their name to booking holdings and now
they sit at a valuation of 94 billion
dollars with a total of 19 400 employees
jay had a 35 stake in the company and
even if we say that stake was watered
down to 20
jay would be worth a little under 20
billion today if he had held on after
leaving priceline jay returned to walker
digital and he's been working there ever
since
as we previously discussed walker
digital is more of a research company as
opposed to a consumer business
so walker digital mainly works in the
background licensing technology and
inventions to other companies like time
warner given that walker digital does
not sell any products themselves many
consider the company to be a patent
troll
and given that jaywalker is the 10th
most patented living inventor today i
don't think that title is necessarily
inaccurate today jaywalker is estimated
to be worth about 500 million dollars so
it doesn't look like jay ever recovered
the money he lost during the dot-com
crash but i don't really think he even
cares to do so
at the end of the day jay was able to go
from zero to over a billion dollars
within a single year thanks to the
explosive success of priceline combined
with the dotcom bubble
though most of jay's wealth was made
within an extremely short period of time
the truth is that priceline's success
was a culmination of decades of
repeatedly starting businesses failing
and trying again nonetheless
so i personally think jay's eventual
success was well deserved even though
there was a good amount of luck mixed in
with this final rise do you guys agree
comment that down below also drop a like
if you respect jay's unwavering
resilience throughout the late 1900s and
of course consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one